you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is around 6
game from the 2015 Tata Steel chess
tournament between the world's top two
players Fabiano Caruana playing his
white world number two against the
current world champion Magnus Carlsen
let's have a look
we have Caruana opening with e4 Carlsen
replying with the Sicilian defense I'd
have three knight c6 we have the Rasul
emo and we go in for that Bishop for
Knight exchange white is now come
batting these this light square bishop
these next two moves at unopposed light
square Bishop d3 and h3 are there and
after a couple more natural moves we
have b6 which is not the most common
seventh move in this opening in this
variation more common is Knight d7 or
castles Knight d7 facilitates e5 looks
to circle around drop the knight into D
for F four but by playing b6 we are at
least on the black side retaining some
flexibility not so quick to move towards
the Queen side even if just for one move
that's so quick to go in that direction
as we'll see in the game he has a
different idea in mind so as a follow up
it's Bishop e3 exerting pressure on c5
paving the way for a battery exchanging
dark square bishop snot a bad idea when
combating the bishop pair and this will
also tie in well with Queen side play as
a follow up we have e5 and I'd like to
draw your attention to the clock times
up to this point Carlsen hasn't spent so
much time and I'm bringing this up
because I believe it's influencing the
play at least at this neck at this
moment here for this move nine the
decision to capture or not we can be
sure that it's going to become a much
more dynamic position if Knight takes a
is played and if you're thinking your
opponent is still well in preparation
it's maybe a wise
decision to simply steer clear of this
particular line even if the evaluation
would be reading whatever that white is
let's say slightly better if you don't
feel comfortable enough going into a
critical dynamic type position maybe
wise again wise to just steer clear of
it and that's what we have in the game
we have castles instead of Knight takes
e5 a look at it and they take see would
be met with Knight takes if we have an
immediate recap shani this is absolutely
no problem black is the one who benefits
the bishop pair is still around in more
pieces more pawns I should say have been
exchanged and that's only benefiting
black but what could follow is after
Knight takes a Knight takes Queen f3
this is a different story putting
pressure on f7 f5 is a reply and now
after Bishop f4 Queen e7 this is as far
as I want to take it again it's a sharp
position if you're not comfortable with
it again not a good feeling to think
your opponent is no longer human but
rather you know this top chess engine
like stockfish you're not enough feeling
comfortable prep wise may be a good
decision to go with castles instead of
this capture so that's where we have
castles it is black follows suit white
gets on with Queen side play black stops
it for the moment and now Queen to be
one white really wants to get this in if
the pawn is allowed to get to b4 we can
say well actually regardless of what
black does next there will be some
weakness imposed on the black Queen side
pawn structure if you're playing a5 to
stop this advance you're weakening b6
and if you allow the b4 advance what's
going to happen well let's see what
happens in the game is Knight h5 we're
seeing that different intention by the
knight he's now drifting towards the
white King
looking to drop into F for one day and
also it's clearing the way for f5 b4 is
now on board and this is the situation
black now finds themself in to take or
just let the pond sit if you're taking
you're helping the rook out which is a
reason to not have had the rook plate of
b1 to facilitate this advance if this
capture is happening the rook is brought
right to life and if you're not
capturing well what's going to happen
well let's see it's what happened in the
game
f5 was played and now B take C f4 is
played first the bishop is kicked back
and now B takes C so this is the cost
black when they were in the position to
take on b4 right here at this stage
after b4 to take or not well if you're
taking you're helping out the rook and
if you don't take you're going to have
double isolated C pawns that's
apparently what black prefers to have
double isolated C pawns instead of
bringing the white rook to life so f4 f5
is on board f4 and only then B takes C
so with this last move will second last
move with this pawn shift here gaining a
tempo against the bishop this structure
starts to remind us of a Kings Indian
defense or in other words where black
looks to play on the King side of the
board and white on the other hand will
look to play on the Queen side of the
board and that's certainly where Y can
be playing there are weaknesses there
that can be targeted and that's exactly
what a Caruana goes for he looks to
target this weakened c5 pawn with both
Queen and Knight and that's what we have
taking shape next starting first with
Queen b3 Bishop e6 Queen a4 she's
looking to drop into a 5 and she's also
putting pressure on c6 that needs to be
tended to if he falls it's it's what's
interesting here is that generally you
see double isolate pawns
very weak but this pond here might be
one of the most valuable ponds in the
position he's controlling a very
critical square d5 without him around
this nights gonna drop right into the
position so need to do something about
that
it's defended with rook to c8 now Queen
a5 pressure on c5 vacating now a4 for
the night c5 is soon to collapse so
Lachlan needs to come up with something
and he does he's pushing forward with a
very clear plan something we would again
see in the Kings Indian defense looking
for a pawn break g4 white gets on with
it Knight a for g4 H takes G that's not
the only move excuse me
you could play Queen takes e5 but I
believe this would simply transpose to
the game after Queen takes e5 they would
follow Queen f6 and then this capture
would happen if you're capturing at this
stage right here after Queen takes C
Queen takes Queen Knight takes Queen
notice the bishop is hit so pawn takes
knight Knight takes bishop so after this
g4 advance we have the immediate capture
Bishop takes an only now Queen takes e5
Queen f6 and now Knight to h2 this is a
big decision here there's also not a lot
of time there's been there's been a lot
of time invested by Caruana at this
stage and white is threat our black
excuse me is threatening to absolutely
crush the white king Side pawn structure
this is a very human-like move but there
was quite a bit of calculation needed at
this stage to do something other than
Knight to H to the computer suggestion
is to get this truck all the way over
here with the idea to allow this capture
and have the Kings sneak over in this
direction and that's actually quite
scary
your king is not going to be able to
tuck himself in so easily on that e2
square for example after Queen h4 you
can't just make a mad dash towards that
e2 square King f1 right away can be met
with Knight g4 this is this is just
going to be very very bad news for a
team way if you're not capturing the
knight well here comes yet another piece
into the attack and if you are capturing
the knight this is bad news
all three of these pieces Queen pawn and
rook are ready to crush that white King
so you can't let me run with this once
more you can't run to f1 right away
however you could play King g2 but this
is like very difficult to see this type
of move King to g2 because it's really
asking for more trouble with rook f6 to
g6 stuff but apparently you can hold
this on the white side and it's very
scary for sure Bishop to b4 looking to
clear the way one day for maybe it came
to c3 move if need being for example if
we have this check now there can follow
king f1 Queen h2 king e - there's a
knight check that can be given there's
also a rook g2 Bishop Bishop to e1 and
the king is looking to run over like so
this is very difficult to see I would
imagine especially with so little time
under 20 minutes or just about 20
minutes to calculate this structural
change and also to know that you can't
just be going very quickly to the e2
square that was my initial thought but
it's it's tactically flawed to have to
meet Queen h4 with King to g2 you're
really you're really having too heavy an
iron stomach I guess you could say
you're really asking for trouble with
this rook g6 stuff so instead it was
again the more human-like move
Knight to h2 and now this is allowing a
big shift in the game we have the follow
up f3 now this night h2 move it wasn't
well it seemed like it was throwing a
punch at the bishop and it is but it
doesn't it isn't something black has to
react to is what I'm getting at f3 is
one way to summarize this is well it's
it's acting as a giant thorn for one in
the white king position until I view it
as helping out both minor pieces this
night will now one day be able to make
use of f4 and pretty much be intolerable
so he'll have to be taken and then when
he is this Bishop will be brought right
to life and he'd even be gaining a tempo
and that a1 rook so this is where
there's a big shift black now starts to
be the better side he's the better side
on the clock and just objectively as
well as a follow up he does go in for
Knight takes Bishop to reply here queen
g6 will win that night right back you
can't just move the knight and defend
the maid on g2 because Knight f4 is a
killer what are you gonna do now g3
that's a million one and then two or if
you like a different square so you can't
you can't just play Knight to e3 Knight
f4 is going to be inked killer so
instead you have to go for a queen
exchange Queen e7 it is there's two ways
to go about that I'm not sure if there's
much difference Queen e7 or III and then
dropping into g5 looking for a queen
exchange and white manages that Queen e7
pawn takes rook has to move you can't
take that pawn you're gonna get killed
it's gonna be a maid already okay three
h3 stuff happening right away
so the wreck has to move he goes to an
open file
Queen takes Knight black out that piece
back and now Queen g5 we have a bit of a
repetition here Queenie - Queen III well
he wants to get the Queen's off the
board and we'll be successful with doing
that so their exchange but there's still
some problems here for a team white
related to that Knight f4 move keeping a
close eye on that G to pawn he's just a
single square away from queening may
seem a bit odd to view it like that but
it does play a role also looking at
simply a fork to pick up that pitch up
so he's pretty much intolerable Bishop
takes Knight pawn takes unleashes the
bishop and is just a moment away from
having a connected past pawn so if
you're reacting in other words to this
threat against your rook at this stage
with c3 this is a killer f3 within rook
F 6 H 6 mate it's not going to be a good
defense to that and we can see how
quickly both players well I should say
you can see how quickly Cara Juana
understood that just looking at the
clock after Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes 11 minutes 18 seconds roughly it's
played very quickly King takes g2 again
there's a 30-second increment here so he
recognized that you just cannot allow
that pawn on g2 you need to just give up
the exchange but black is not so quick
to invest that Bishop for Knight
exchange he's looking at different ideas
the follow up here is f3 maybe he'll
take the rook maybe he won't let's see
what your kings gonna do first if you
play up to g3 maybe there's a reason to
be making use of the e5 square or maybe
better stated you want to first play f3
so that you keep these options available
where maybe you could question the king
being on a dark square over here on the
Kings side so first it's f3 let's grab
grab some more information about the
white king and let's also make sure he
not able to find a good home on the f3
square so f3 first King f1 and not
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes Knight
would still have an advantage do Bishop
takes Knight there's still an advantage
for black but it's not so clear it's
much better to go after the King getting
a rook let's say to this h1 square
rook to f4 not going for material going
for mate instead c3 saves the rook cuts
off this diagonal and you can also view
it as having now a new square for the
King that's probably the more important
feature here because when the rook is on
h4 just trying to run to this D 2 square
that's not necessarily a square you can
rely upon because the bishop can play to
h6 and control it so c3 is interfering
with Bishop takes rook but primary
purpose is to have that c2 squared
available for the King has a follow-up
we have rook to e8 all three pieces are
working these two right here they don't
move anymore in this game that's all we
had by this knight Knight c3 to a4 this
rope hasn't moved and it's just there's
not a way not a good defense here for
white in the game we had d4 and then the
follow up Bishop to h6 this was not the
most convincing move but it's still
going to score the point better move
would have been route to h4 immediately
looking for me and after King to e1 to
crash through on d4 with the Bishop
after pawn takes rook takes you cannot
stop mate so and while doing something
else after Bishop takes here if you're
well this isn't a defense but just to
show it after rook to d1 this is nothing
because you could still take here it's
now a double attack in some sense
against the d2 Square after the bishop
is captured that's me
we didn't have that we didn't have rip
to h4 but instead Bishop to h6 the king
goes for a little bit of a run and now
this rook is picking up some ponds c5 is
a nice shot here if you're going in for
this rook e to move getting on the
second-ranked right away it could be
challenged with rook to Beto the knight
is there to defend and so by playing
first c5 if Knight takes pawn now now
this rook to e2 move would be that much
more devastating hitting at f2 and it
cannot be challenged with rook to be to
the Knights no longer there to defend
so after c5 we have the King running
this position is getting completely
broken down king d3 rookie to c4 the
king position is secure but after rook
takes pawn it's black who's now up what
four pawns to two very active rook
Bishop all pieces playing there's really
no hope here after rip to e2 Caruana
throws in the towel there's nothing to
do here down material black also has the
superior minor piece looking at these
checks with pawn pushes to passed pawns
it's too much so a very interesting game
right out of the opening decision points
looking at preparation a little bit
believe that influence playing
especially right here to go in for that
dynamic play or not Queen side play
again similar to what we would have in a
Kings Indian defense black playing on
the King side white going on the Queen
side where black is weakened pinpointing
that c5 pawn meanwhile black gets on
with a g4 break and again right here you
have to have an iron stomach for it but
allowing this type of pawn
transformation it's certainly scary in
the face of these three pieces attacking
your king but objectively best but very
very difficult to play for a human
instead Knight h2 and again that f3 move
allowed the knight and the bishop to
spring to life that f4 square being made
use of soon
the queens are off just a little bit but
the attack continued not giving that
bishop up for the rook instead going for
the king's throw and black of course was
successful after breaking down this
white king position so that's all for
this video as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye
you